after russia annexed crimea in 2014 and
faced sanctions imposed by the west
russian president vladimir putin turned
to china and his friend president xi
jinping
[Music]
that may the two countries signed a 400
billion gas supply agreement since then
cooperation between putin and ji has
only strengthened and back in february
the two leaders declared that their
friendship had no limits but now
russia's violent invasion of ukraine is
testing the strength of that partnership
and with fears that beijing could help
moscow as it continues its military
assault on ukraine that partnership is
being watched closely around the world
china will bear responsibility for any
actions it takes to support russia's
aggression the cost of this war for
china
could potentially be very high i spoke
to my colleague ling ling wei wsj's
chief china correspondent about three
ways that the war in ukraine is weighing
on china
first there's china's economy which is
important not just to the chinese
population but to president xi
personally since he's seeking to extend
his rule for an unprecedented third term
this fall for him stability economic
stability political stability social
stability really becomes everything else
so the ukraine crisis really made his
existing domestic economic challenge
much harder not only are china's
businesses and manufacturers being hit
by soaring commodity prices and supply
chain breakdowns sparked by the war
they're scrambling to assess the risk of
becoming collateral damage when it comes
to the west's sanctions on russia they
do not want to lose access to markets in
the developed world markets are way more
important
to china than the russian market plus
for china this economic turmoil being
brought on by the war is coming on top
of economic pain that was already caused
by the pandemic and president g's
crackdown on capitalist forces something
he's rolled back recently the war is
also threatening china's global image
and its efforts to be seen as a peaceful
and benevolent superpower beijing has
denied knowing about putin's invasion
plans in advance and it has repeatedly
called for dialogue to resolve the
crisis but just weeks before the
invasion began putin and g held a summit
and released a 5 000 word statement
outlining a vision for a new world order
that caused many in the west to label
china and russia a new axis by tilting
toward russia
on the eve of the invasion
china has basically painted itself as an
enabler of sort of a country that is now
being universally condemned ling ling
says that contradicts china's efforts to
uphold itself as a responsible
stakeholder in global affairs for
example china has promoted itself as a
well-intentioned world power by
investing in infrastructure projects in
other countries offering kovid 19
vaccines to the developing world and
stepping up efforts to work with
international organizations like the un
so why is there even a question of
whether china would help or even
remain close to russia at this point
that's a great question xi jinping
definitely has an interest in keeping
russia around as an ally both are
authoritarians and nationalists with the
desire to really raise their country's
statue and challenge the us-led world
order so far china has declined to
criticize russia or describe its actions
in ukraine as an invasion chinese
officials have blamed the us for
provoking russia and third russia's
invasion of ukraine has put a fresh
spotlight on china's intentions when it
comes to taiwan which beijing sees as
part of china the u.s has strengthened
ties with the self-governed democratic
island in recent years i think the scale
of the u.s and its allied response to
the war and the scale of sanctions have
really
surprised many people in china china
hasn't given an indication that it plans
to take action on taiwan in the near
future but it has raised tensions by
flying fighter jets near the island and
ramping up the military pressure western
officials worry that with putin arguing
that ukraine is historically part of
russia china could be encouraged to make
a similar argument to try to bring
taiwan into its fold as russia's war in
ukraine grinds on and as china continues
to face pressure in responding to it we
will have all of the updates at wsj.com
and if you thought this video was
informative hit the like button and
subscribe to the channel for more
stories like this i'll see you next time
[Music]